bonsoir soyez les bienvenus au village
des jeux équestres mondiaux bienvenue en
basse-normandie un village en fête
puisque la france a décroché sa deuxième
médaille et c'est de l'argent par
équipes en saut d'obstacles et ce sont
trois cavalli bas normands qui apporte
cette médaille à la france à kevin staut
pénélope leprévost et patrice delaveau
c'est l'image du jour un de ces jeux
quel bonheur pour les cavaliers bas
normands ils sont en effet de peu pour
se hisser sur la première marche du
podium le suspense a été maintenu
jusqu'au bout je vous propose d'écouter
cette belle équipe de france interviewé
il y à quelques minutes par corinne
queiroz a alors une médaille d'argent
est ce que c'est un métal qui vous va ce
soir
on aurait pu avec un tout petit peu plus
de chance où on aurait plus je pense
accro à accrocher l'or maintenant on
était 4e hier soir donc on est quand
même très heureux d'avoir de finir ce
championnat par équipes sur le podium
c'est déjà une très bonne chose de faite
que l'émotion est là même qui a quatre
ans on est chez nous quand même notre
public c'est pas c'est ce qu'on disait
pour profiter non seulement de la
médaille et en plus c'est ici il y avait
tous nos proches nos amis notre famille
et notre public
oui surtout ce qu'on disait sur le
chemin pour venir vous voir c'est que
chacun participe et cette médaille par
équipes c'est vraiment le travail de
toute l'équipe
on a raté certains parcours d'autres ont
réussi les choses sont un père changé
quand je pense que pour en profiter on
en profite tous tous ensemble avec notre
public c'est vrai que je pense qu'elle a
une superbe voix
là est celui que vous n'avez pas entendu
c'est simon delestre qui fait bien
partie de cette équipe de france mais
pour le classement par équipes et bien
on retient les temps des trois meilleurs
cavaliers les trois meilleurs
aujourd'hui c'était kevin staut pénélope
leprévost et patrice delaveau bonsoir
anthony masto soir mais on va revenir
avec vous sur cette fois l'après midi
qu'il ya très longtemps que je n'avais
pas eu autant de noeuds dans le ventre
en regardant une épreuve de saut
d'obstacles quel suspense et quelle
ambiance dans ce stade un vrai chaudron
et c'est avec cette pression que simon
delestre a ouvert le bal pour la france
sur classiques bois margot il est alors
16h25 la france est pour le moment
quatrième et cette petite faute cette
barre qui coûte 4 points mais un peu
plus la pression sur la france
maintenant les autres cavaliers français
n'ont plus le choix il faut des sans
faute pour monter sur le podium
16h57 autour de pénélope leprévost et
flora de mariposa d'entrer sur la piste
une reprise un peu forte sur la jeune
jument donne quelques frissons à l'abord
du trip mais ça fasse en tribune vous
allez voir patrice delaveau accompagne
tous les sauts c'est finalement un sans
faute pour la française est une clameur
dans le stade
la france remonte mais pénélope
leprévost ne se réjouit pas encore
écoutez
franchement magique parce que moi j'ai
très très mal mende et moi juste
l'énergie y était moi j'ai fait une
foule et de mort à deux endroits ne
pouvait plus à un nouveau tracé
ressemble à rien mais elle voulait
aujourd'hui
il ne reste alors que deux cavaliers
français à passer de son côté
l'allemagne elle faiblit un peu 7h15
c'est au tour de kevin staut de passer
la ligne de départ tout le monde retient
son souffle une petite touche sur le
numéro 4 mais ça tient 2e 100 foot pour
la france et la pression qui s'accentue
alors pour le dernier cavalier français
à passer si patrice delaveau fait un
sans faute c'est le titre pour la france
hélas hélas hélas il y a cette barre
maintenant moi une très belle médaille
d'argent au final la médaille d'or
pour les états unis patrice delaveau lui
est toujours en course pour le titre en
individuel quel après-midi chemli et à
l'après midi on va les rejoindre et
jacques legoupil notre consul mais aussi
le speaker de ce concours de saut
d'obstacles et comme l'épreuve s'est
terminée tard et bien andré jacques vous
n'êtes pas avec nous sur le plateau mais
vous avez vous raconter cette folle
journée vu du dernier étage du stade
d'ornano vous êtes installés pour
commenter cette épreuve écoutez je vais
essayer de pas avoir de trémolos dans la
voix parce que l'émotion elle est encore
là comme vient de le dire anthony ça a
été une après-midi vraiment folle moi je
restais ici j'avoue que si je suis déçu
tu peux être avec vous je regrette pas
parce que jusqu'à il ya encore quelques
secondes tous les cavaliers étaient là
avec les bénévoles avec les bénévoles de
la piste à faire des photos ait rappelé
aux 10 était il y avait du bonheur j'ai
pas si vous souvenez du coach sur le
plateau il ya quelques jours je suis sûr
quand on écoutera son interview qu il
n'aurait pas forcément misé sur une
telle performance donc la bonne heure de
folie et surtout une fierté d'avoir vécu
ça avec un public aussi waouh hors du
commun sport fair-play attentif
concentré magnifique magnifique avec un
f majuscule voilà merci andré jacquot on
retrouve demain soir à 19h patrick
armand est avec nous bonjour bonsoir
vous êtes l'ancien entraîneur national
de l'équipe de france de cso de 85 à 98
vous allez apporter vos dires 118
médaille à la france était une grande
époque comment avez vous vécu cette
journée vous étiez dans nos mains total
a alors la france a été
médaille d'or par équipe en 82 aken
bronze en 86
aken pardon or c'était dublin 90 or à
stockholm argent 94 argent 98 2002 or
avec jean maurice bonneau comme
entraîneur en 2010 alexis nihon médaille
médaille d'argent par équipes et la
médaille d'argent
par équipe avec gaza en argent puis avec
une cavalière trois cavaliers des
chevaux extraordinaire des propriétaires
derrière qui aide est vraiment
l'équitation en france et ça c'est
merveilleux parce que il y a une réelle
continuité ce n'est pas un accident il y
as d'intelligence en france alors vous
les connaissez bien ses cavaliers
notamment patrice delaveau que vous avez
connue de tous jeunes et moins jeunes
oui parce que ans en 1982
pendant 1986 avec sa chapelle il était
une médaille de bronze par équipes il
n'avait que 20 ans il monte est un choix
des relations qui s'appelle laquelle
donc le retrouver ici sur le podium
c'est fantastique ça veut dire que c'est
un sport que l'on peut faire jusqu'à un
âge très avancé en étant très
performants nous avons ici un cahier
canadien il ya millar qui a participé à
dix jeux olympiques déguise 67 ans est
encore un membre important de son équipe
car aux gars vous portez sur
l'équitation quand vous étiez entraîneur
donc dans les années 80 jusqu'à 98
aujourd'hui en 2014 est ce que ça a
évolué et est ce que ça va dans le bon
sens ou pas
les champions d'aujourd'hui seront les
champions de demain les champions d'hier
auraient pu être les champions
d'aujourd'hui il faut savoir respecter
le passé savourer le présent et avoir
confiance dans le futur non je crois que
on a encore un bel avenir on a un bel
élevage en france on a des bons
cavaliers on a des propriétaires
passionnés donc savourons cette médaille
d'argent là un goût extraordinaire parce
que médaille d'argent dans ce pays c'est
encore plus fort qu'une médaille
d'argent à l'autre bout du monde mais
peut-être en ans rue où c'est encore une
à bromont dans quatre ans au canada
alors parlons de ce qui va venir c'est à
dire
la médaille individuelle avec la finale
à 4 dimanche
je sais que vous dites pas que cette
question est quand même un pronostic ou
pas de qui faut-il se méfier alors très
complexe puisque à l'issue de cette
épreuve par équipe la france on le
rappelle est médaille d'argent les 30
meilleurs cavaliers vont disputer samedi
une épreuve qui sera très intense très
délicate à l'issue de laquelle les
quatre meilleurs cavaliers au cavaliere
j'espère qu'il y aura une française
disputeront une finale tournante où les
cavaliers à tour de rôle montrent leurs
chevaux sur une épreuve très réduite et
avec décote vraiment baissé pour bien
respecter les chevaux mais c'est une
épreuve très complexe on ne peut pas
faire de pronostics
quand même non un malaise passant
mondino on a quatre français dans les 30
nos cavaliers à trois cavaliers donc moi
j'ai eu la chance de vivre à stockholm
deux cavaliers en finale dans l'es4 et
de terminer médailles d'or et de bronze
bon rêvons mais bon on verra ça revo
merci patrick caron alors nous
reviendrons jeux équestres mondiaux un
peu plus tard l'actualité de ce jeudi 15
septembre c'est cette molécule que des
chercheurs canet vient de mettre au
point et qui redonne un peu d'espoir aux
personnes souffrant de la maladie
d'alzheimer
elle a été élaborée au centre d'études
et de recherche sur le médicament de
normandie et elle pourrait stopper
l'évolution de cette maladie qui touche
44 millions de personnes dans le monde
quesnel louis et saint marc dans ce
ballon j'ai à peu près 20 mg de cette
molécule de données cloud quelques
milligrammes met beaucoup d'espoir dans
cette molécule créé ici dans ce
laboratoire canet
voici de près se donner aux prix d' il
permettrait d'agir ce second tome de la
maladie d'alzheimer mais aurait
également des vertus curatives
un patient atteint de la maladie vers la
mémoire il voit un concert qu'on a trop
fier suite à la destruction de neurones
plusieurs causes ont été identifiés
l'apparition de plaques séniles d'une
part et la dégénérescences
neurofibrillaires de l'autre
notre molécule donné qu au prix d aviser
les plaques séniles en réduisant la
formation de celle ci et en promouvant à
la plate la formation d'une protéine qui
elle et neuroprotectrices c'est donc un
grand bénéfice que va pouvoir exercer
ainsi la molécule le dos n'est qu'au
prix d' a été testé sur des souris qu
elles sont curieuses et aiment les
nouveaux objets leur comportement a
permis de mesurer leur mémoire chez ces
souris nous avons pu augmenter leurs
performances de mémoire chez des animaux
sains en prolongeant leur capacité de
mémoire dans ce test caractéristiques
d'autres essais ont été faits sur des
souris transgéniques présentant des
troubles à ses ports d'alzheimer des
résultats sur leur cerveau ont été
concluants les plaques séniles ont été
diminués tout a été publié au journal de
l'académie des sciences des états unis
reste à transformer cette molécule en
médicaments et c'est là que ça se
complique il manque un ingrédient
indispensable l'argent entre 800
millions et un milliard d'euros
maintenant à la rentrée est la réforme
des rythmes scolaires instauré l'an
dernier pour les communes qui les
choisit de se donner un an de plus pour
la mettre en place c'est le grand saut
c'est le cas pour la communauté de
communes de 2000 et dans le calvados
cette réforme va coûter 150 mille euros
à rennes limogés et frau
jamais une rentrée ne leur avait donné
autant de fil à retordre il la préparait
depuis 18 mois
les trois quarts d'entre eux était resté
cet après midi pourtant il n'y avait pas
école c'était déjà et scolaires et ce
sera comme ça tout le jeudi avec des
ateliers différents qui respecte les
rythmes évidemment tous les rythmes
pour les plus petits c'était encore lent
de la sieste tandis que les sections
périeure s'initiaient à la couleurs et
aux formes en douceur
on apprend
qu'il
a fait c'est la nuit excédé vénérable
association spécialisée dans les loisirs
éducatifs et l'animation que les élus
ont confié l'organisation de ses
activités en lien avec les personnels
municipaux
les associations locales
voulue pour l'école maternelle que les
enfants soient dépaysés possible donc
ils sont dans leurs yeux ils sont aussi
avec des femmes des atsem qui sont des
qui ont bien voulu passer attache à la
plupart et leurs enfants une vingtaine
de contrats ont été signés mais de
quelques heures l'équivalent de trois
emplois à temps plein et pourtant ça
coûte très cher
pour la communauté de communes ces cent
cinquante mille euros pour 405 enfants
ça fait plus tout 100 euros par enfant
c'est un
pas forcément
c'est cher et compliqué mais vous en
connaissez beaucoup vous des gens qui
vont profiter gratuitement de jeux
équestres toute l'année
on y reviendra d'abord économique la
mauvaise santé du bâtiment dans le
calvados la fédération tire la sonnette
d'alarmé on entend les mises en
chantiers de constructions neuves ont
baissé de 26% la fédération compte
néanmoins sur les dernières mesures
gouvernementales pour relancer le
secteur à damien mignot
leur passé en basse-normandie 1500
salariés auraient perdu leur emploi et
les premières tendances pour l'année
2014 serait tout aussi mauvaise
les licenciements ou fermetures
d'entreprises liées à un contexte
économique défavorable
les chiffres sont là ils ne sont pas
bons est à moins pour le moins 20% terme
de permis de construire et d'ouverture
de chantier ce qui a pour corollaire des
carnets de commande au plus bas
des trésoriers d'entreprise forcément en
difficulté parce qu'il ya une grosse
pression sur les prix une situation de
crise qui pèse fortement sur la
croissance globale du pays le 29 août
manuel valls a annoncé un certain nombre
de mesures censées relancer la machine
btp
ça passe par la libération du foncier ça
passe aussi par
le fait que les primo accédants ont
pouvoir bénéficier du prêt à taux zéro
ça passe aussi la rénovation énergétique
et le remplacement du politique du flou
qui nous a fait beaucoup de tort la
fédération du bâtiment demande au
gouvernement un choc de confiance avec
une libéralisation du marché et une
stabilité dans les décisions
gouvernementales
en général il faut attendre 18 mois
avant que de nouvelles mesures se
ressent au sein des entreprises
allaient revenons aux jeux équestres
mondiaux aujourd'hui n'avait pas que du
saut d'obstacles il y avait également de
la voltige avec les épreuves techniques
individuelles hommes et femmes anthony
exactement emilie et dans cette épreuve
le voltigeur doit enchaîner cinq figures
de son choix les exécuter le mieux
possible chez les hommes très belle
performance de nicolas andréani une fois
de plus magique très vite on oublier le
côté sportif on entre dans le monde de
l'artiste qui s'y rend hommage au monde
du cirque
l'interprétation continue même après le
salut beaucoup de talent chez ce jeune
homme qui a fini 2e aujourd'hui et on
espère vraiment vraiment une médaille
d'or vendredi soir il la mérite jolie
prestation aussi pour jacques ferrari
tout dans l'interprétation là encore est
une troisième place dans cette épreuve
on espère également une médaille pour
lui vendredi soir
chez les femmes on valoir un peu moins
bien pour anne sophie lucet sur papillon
plume elle termine la 7e place le midi
et demain ce sont les finales de voltige
hommes femmes et par équipe par équipe
10 nations vont concourir parmi
lesquelles la nouvelle zélande qui peut
condé se compter sur des supporters
aurélie misery espagne deux prochaines
rencontres et deux mamans qui ont
parcouru 20 mille kilomètres pour aller
encourager leur fille regarder
ce n'est pas la distance qu'ils allaient
les de courage et elles ont parcouru
près de 20000 km juliet simone son musée
landaise et si l on fasse aussi long
voyage jusqu'en moment dit c'est que ces
deux mamans sont les premières fans de
leur filière jetez vos enfants j'avais
cinq ans quand ils ont commencé et les
voir ici participer aux compétitions
nationales
c'est juste quelque chose sont avérées
fait depuis si longtemps
comme j'aurais été déçu de ne pas être
venu ici si j'avais dû regarder la
compétition depuis chez moi être là bas
loin donc ici eh bien non je suis très
content d'être venu
c'est le jour du programme libre des
épreuves de voltige par équipes juliet
simone sur le zénith de caen
mais avec le corps qui m'a un peu plus
fort
maintenant c'est parti ça j'en pense
qu'on a tant travaillé donc bonne chance
je n'ai commencé
leur parce que cela représente les dix
dernières années de ma vie sow mais cela
valait le coup
et on va en finale
moi je sais pas si c'est un compliment
ça emmanuel chaunu aller s'était
également aujourd'hui le début des
épreuves d'attelage sur l'hippodrome de
la prairie la plage c'est un peu comme
le concours complet ça se déroule en
trois épreuves le dressage le marathon
et la maniabilité anthony exactement un
millier avec aujourd'hui le début des
épreuves de dressage les concurrents
sont notés sur leur style la qualité des
allures mais aussi sur la présentation
de leur attelage d'ailleurs même si on
ne s'y connaît pas et qu'on ne comprend
pas forcément toujours la subtilité des
figures il faut aller voir ces épreuves
pour la beauté de ses voitures et de ses
chevaux haute forme beaux costumes
belles voitures jolis chevaux et jolie
harnais c'est vraiment un plaisir pour
les yeux sur le plan sportif aujourd'hui
trois des huit meneur français concours
et thibault coudry benjamin aillaud et
sébastien monnier reprise correcte il
faut maintenant attendre la suite du
concours demain pour voir comment s'en
sort la france sur cette épreuve on
suivra notamment de près le normand
fabrice martin je suis sûr qu'en voyant
ces images emilie vos rêves de
princesses et de carros revient au grand
galop donc c'est thibault coudry qu'on a
vu au début c'est un ancien rugbyman
voyez là un fait grave en fait il faut
bien reconnaître leur stage en attelage
c'est parfois assez difficile à
comprendre quand on est quand on n'est
pas des milieux mais vous allez le voir
ça n'empêche pas certains néophytes d'y
prendre un certain plaisir reportage de
pierre marc épuré le ciel duponchel
lesnumeriques
surtout pas des publiquement quand
l'attelage entre sur la piste pendant
l'épreuve de dressage le silence est
requis c'est comme au tennis on n'a pas
le droit de rentrer tant que les joueurs
sont dans l'arène
le lac au milieu des poteaux
alors à défaut de pouvoir applaudir jean
et jean livres vont de leur commentaire
est
une vieille ford alors c'est
téléphone quelques jours
l'entrée le snu le trou le virage tout
est codifié tout est noté reste encore à
pouvoir d'écouté et envoie des visites
sur place
une mère de masse tous les angles watts
et ça fait une erreur celle du travail
de précision
et les beaux sports
bien en ligne
ces pluies depuis tous ses leaders
finissez par le coup d'oeil bah on
apprend vite on apprend à ouais mais bon
on est des dégâts la nature on est légal
de l agriculture arnal a filmé sur vous
madame royal et myler va faire un
malheur
par contre ce que je comprends pas c'est
le mot du classement les notes ici c'est
pas les mêmes qu'à la fin alors j'ai pas
compris encore pourquoi c'est être que
j'arriverai à comprendre un jour
te dis mais ce que vous aussi vous était
un gars de la nature l'agenda devenant
alors au programme demain de la voltige
avec les finales pas de 2 à 10 heures
finales individuelles hommes et femmes
en début d'après-midi et puis les
finales par équipes le soir on va suivre
tout ça de l'attelage aussi à partir de
9h30 avec la suite des épreuves de
faîtage fallait retrouver à les deux
acolytes là elle nous fallait retrouver
sur le village des jeux hélène jacques
qui est accompagné de louis bertignac
qui se produit ce soir en concert au
village des jeux oui bonsoir abily
bonsoir à tous une fuite plutôt bien
l'accompagner ce soir effectivement on
n'est pas sur le village on a un petit
peu l'après des loges on est mieux on
est un peu plus tranquille je suis avec
mu bertignac qui va passer ce soir en
concert qu'est-ce que vous figure du
rock français venaient faire ici au
j'aime bien écouter on may ont m'a
appelé pour venir faire de la musique et
voilà comme ailleurs on m'appelle je
joue et vous aimez ça mais est ce que ça
vous parle ce monde de l'équitation les
chevaux ou c'est un monde à part c'est
pas vraiment mon monde parce que je suis
pratiquement jamais monter à cheval
j avais jamais à auteuil longchamp avec
mon pape quand j'étais petit il misé
toujours sur un cheval ou des mots si je
réussissais les numéros pour lui mais
voilà quoi
trouve des fonds très beau j'adore leur
faire des câlins mais si tout va alors
vous êtes ici en concert ce soit avec un
nouvel album suis moi alors on en est
c'est quoi c'est du rock poétique dames
elodie c'est du rock bob
six mois de préparation c'est ça oui
disons trois ans de travail en général
de composition et puis réalisations
pendant six mois mais est-ce qu en
concert ce soir la question on aura du
téléphone ou pas du téléphone huawei a
toujours bien toujours chez le chat sont
sans rayons ça c'est vraiment toi new
york avec toi et voilà et pour le reste
il faut venir tout à l'heure c'est à 21h
louis et 21h c'est ça faudra venir
écouter regarder encore montre là devant
sa peine je suis moi voilà
on a pu le temps là merci elle tous les
temps
merci à tous les deux alors c'est une
tendance ces dernières années de plus en
plus de people on pense pour
l'équitation soit parce qu'ils aiment
monter à cheval ou soit parce qu'ils
aiment l'équitation tout court c'est le
cas de charles berling qui est toujours
séquestrés pendant deux jours écoutez le
à chaque fois qu'on voit des concours
comme ça c'est tout à fait passionnant
il ya une
virtuosité il ya une grâce dans danser
dans ce sport et en même temps une
passion qui n'est enfin on a vu un
public complètement remonter c'est voilà
je pense d'ailleurs que le sport
équestre va gagner beaucoup en comme le
tennis un moment donné a appris ce nom
sont souvent son essor le le golfe voyez
donc l'équipe à sion va devenir je pense
à ce sport très populaire
cet après midi sur le plateau nos
copains de france télé sport
l'équitation c'est quand même 700 me
licencier 1 c'est déjà populaire à l'est
la chronique de mathieu bellingen les
pieds dans le crottin ce soir mathieu on
très au sérieux les nouvelles heures
avec de sécurité mises en place après
les nombreuses chutes regarder
on l'a vu hier avec la chute du cavalier
chilien le sport équestre est dangereux
et en conséquence l'organisation des
jeux équestres a décidé de réagir et
d'imposer le port d'une protection à
tous les cavaliers alors ça va être
difficile de faire des épreuves avec ce
genre de protection monsieur ce n'est
pas trop loin un petit peu aux 35 kg
quoi mais bon c'est pour réserver pour
toutes les époques
c'est nécessaire c'est nécessaire parce
que en effet et bien l'élan ce qui
arrive en face sont quand même très
résistante quoi ça fait combien de kilos
ça ça fait quarante kilos finalement
on vous souhaite bonne chance monsieur
d'entendre ce concours de saut
d'obstacles et de deux lances un que
vous allez à ce contexte euler
l'équitation c'est pas sexy emmanuel
cioni conclu avec le nouveau casque de
françois hollande là parce qu'il a
beaucoup tu as à faire avec valérie
trierweiler voilà il est armé notre
françois bonne soirée mais oui alors
c'est normal avant de se quitter donnez
moi non même s'il vous plaît et monique
ont cherché qui tenait bon
pratiquement plus de norman le comité
d'organisation est presque en rupture de
stock et les mascottes bien qu'ils
restent sont mises en vente au
compte-gouttes donc vaut mieux se lever
tôt le matin dans un instant la météo
l'édition nationale le résumé des jeux
c'est dans le soir 3 demain midi vous
retrouver à oman de milhac à 19h au
sylvain rouil moi je vous donne
rendez-vous et qu'anthony masto samedi
et dimanche à 12h45 pour nos émissions
de spécial merci à tous les trois merci
mon colonel c'est comme ça quand vous
appelez quand vous êtes entraîneur de
l'équipe de violence très bonne soirée
et puis à très bientôt et avec ces
images l'image du jour le podium par
équipes
l'argent pour la france par équipe en
saut d'obstacles bravo kevin staut
pénélope leprévost et patrice delaveau
très bonne soirée